>> Tucker: IF YOU'RE THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY OF NEW
YORK, YOU'RE CALLING EVERY
UNION LEADER AND HACK AND
SHOVELING CASH TO KEEP LEE
ZELDIN FROM WINNING.
HE COULD BE THE NEXT
GOVERNOR OF NEW YORK, A
STATE THAT WENT FOR BIDEN
BY 23 POINTS.
WHAT'S THAT ABOUT?
SIMPLE.
VIOLENT CRIME.
IT IS OUT OF CONTROL,
PARTICULARLY IN NEW YORK
CITY, DESTROYING THE CITY.
FOR EXAMPLE, AROUND 5:30
A.M. THIS MORNING IN NEW
YORK, A HOMELESS MAN WITH
25 PRIOR ARRESTS, A
SUSPECT IN PREVIOUS SEXUAL
ASSAULTS WHO WAS OUT ON
THE STREET, THAT MAN RAPED
AND ROBBED A 43-YEAR-OLD
WOMAN OUT JOGGING IN THE
WEST VILLAGE, PROBABLY THE
NICEST PART OF THE CITY.
AGAIN, THIS GUY WAS
ALREADY WANTED FOR TWO
PRIOR SEX CRIMES.
ONE OF THEM BACK IN APRIL
SEXUAL ASSAULTED A
DIFFERENT WOMAN OUT FOR A
JOG.
IN OCTOBER, TRIED TO RIP
THE CLOTHES OFF A
48-YEAR-OLD WOMAN WALKING
ON FDR DRIVE AND THEN
TRIED TO RAPE HER.
WHY WAS THIS GUY WALKING
AROUND THE CITY THIS
MORNING.
THE REAL QUESTION IS WHERE
WAS KATHY HOCHUL, GREAT
DEFENDER OF WOMEN?
SHE'S A WOMAN, BIG
FEMINIST.
DID KATHY HOCHUL SAY
ANYTHING ABOUT THIS TODAY,
ANYTHING?
IT IS ONE OF THE BIGGEST
ISSUES.
NO, SHE SAID NOTHING.
SHE TALKED GUN CONTROL
WHICH NEW YORK HAS HAD FOR
60 YEARS.
STRICTER GUN CONTROL.
HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH GUN
CONTROL, THIS IS RAPE AND
IT HAS GONE WAY UP IN NEW
YORK UNDER HEAT INKATHY HOCHUL.
REGISTERED VOTERS SHOW 82%
OF BLACK DEMOCRATS BELIEVE
VIOLENT CRIME IS A QUOTE,
VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE.
YOU KNOW WHO DOESN'T CARE
ABOUT VIOLENT CRIME?
PEOPLE THAT DON'T HAVE TO
DEAL WITH IT.
ONLY 33% OF WHITE LIBERALS
CARE.
HUH.
WHAT EXPLAINS THE
DIFFERENCE.
LARRY ELDERS, CANDIDATE
FOR GOVERNOR IN CALIFORNIA
HOST OF LARRY ELDER SHOW
JOINS US NEXT.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
YOU WOULD THINK IF YOU ARE
A FEMINIST CANDIDATE AND
EMPOWER WOMEN, GIRL POWER,
AND YOU'RE KATHY HOCHUL
AND PEOPLE ARE BEING RAPED
IN HUGE NUMBERS IN YOUR
STATE YOU WOULD SAY
SOMETHING ABOUT IT MAYBE?
>> WELL, YOU WOULD THINK
SO.
AND THAT POLL IS VERY
TELLING.
82% OF BLACK DEMOCRATS
BELIEVE CRIME IS A VERY
SERIOUS PROBLEM, ONLY 33%
OF WHITE DEMOCRATS FEEL
THAT WAY.
AS YOU POINTED OUT, THAT'S
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE TO
FACE THE CONSEQUENCES.
THIS IS NOT ALL THAT
SURPRISING.
THERE'S A WEBSITE CALLED
POLICE MAG.COM, AND THOSE
WHO ARE SELF DESCRIBED,
TUCKER, AS VERY LIBERAL
WERE ASKED HOW MANY
UNARMED BLACK MEN DID THE
POLICE KILL IN 2019.
HALF OF THEM THOUGHT THEY
KILLED 1,000, AND 5%
THOUGHT THEY KILLED 10,000
UNARMED BLACK MEN.
ANSWER ACCORDING TO "THE
WASHINGTON POST" DATABASE
WAS 12.
THEY'RE NOT CONCERNED
ABOUT CRIME BUT ARE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE
SYSTEMIC RACISM BY THE
POLICE, WHY YOU HAVE ALL
OF THE D.A.s MANY BACKED
BY GEORGE SOROS MONEY,
CASHLESS BAIL, LETTING
PEOPLE ON THE STREETS.
BELIEVE THEY'RE VICTIMS OF
SOCIETY INSTEAD OF
VICTIMIZING.
>> Tucker: I AM WONDERING,
REPUBLICANS LIKELY ZELDIN
RUNNING ON THIS MESSAGE
ARE DOING WELL.
WHY ISN'T EVERY
REPUBLICAN, THIS IS A
CIVILIZATION ISSUE.
WHY ISN'T EVERY REPUBLICAN
RUNNING ON IT.
>> ALL THE ONES I TALK TO,
CAROLINE LEVITT RUNNING IN
NEW HAMPSHIRE, CRIME IS AN
ISSUE AROUND THE COUNTRY
AND SHOULD BE, I WANT TO
TALK MORE ABOUT THE WHITE
LIBERAL THING.
WHITE LIBERALS ARE OFTEN
CLEAR AND PRESENT DANGER
TO BLACK PEOPLE.
WHITE LIBERALS
INCENTIVIZED WOMEN TO
MARRY THE GOVERNMENT, AND
YOU HAVE 70% OF BLACK BOYS
AND GIRLS ENTERING THE
WORLD WITHOUT A FATHER
MARRYING THE MOTHER.
WHEN WE HAD THE RECESSION
A BUNCH OF PEOPLE GOT
WIPED OUT.
BLACK NET WORTH FELL
DRAMATICALLY.
THESE ARE WHITE LIBERALS.
QUICK POINT.
ONE OF MY FRIENDS IS THE
ECONOMIST, WALTER
WILLIAMS.
HE WROTE A COLUMN WHERE HE
ISSUED PROCLAMATION GIVING
WHITE PEOPLE FOR ALL THE
BAD THINGS IN THE PAST TO
STOP ACTING LIKE FOOLS
BECAUSE YOU'RE HURTING US.
>> MALCO